we writers are trained by the business
we are trained to believe what we do is
secondary to what they do we are trained
to do the bidding of people who are
motivated not by curiosity but by
protecting their jobs and we lose sight
of what our work is it is not to
contribute to their fortunes or our own
it is not to please them or critics or
even the audiences who have also been
trained our work is to reflect the world
say what is true in the face of so much
lying the world is a mess the world is
beautiful the world is impossibly
complicated and we have the opportunity
to explore that if we give that up for
the carrot then we might as well be the
executives you don't work for the world
of box office numbers you work for the
world they've tricked us into thinking
we can't do it without them but the
truth is they cannot do anything of
value without us thank you
all right